les missiles russes sont encore des
victimes en Ukraine en banlieue de
carquif un homme a trouvé la mort et
deux personnes ont été blessées à Odessa
c'est un entrepôt du port qui a été
détruit faisant un mort et un blessé
pourtant encore une fois les autorités
ukrainiennes affirment avoir battu en
vol la presque totalité des missiles
russes 29 sur 30 donc des missiles
kinjan
mardi déjà l'Ukraine avait annoncé avoir
intercepté six missile supersonique
kingjal la fine fleur de l'armement
russe
ses missiles étaient réputés imparables
ce qui serait un coup dur pour Moscou
des débris de l'un d'eux ont même été
exhibé le 12 mai par un expert d'un
laboratoire militaire de Kiev avec à
l'appui tous les numéros de série
pire encore pour Moscou les militaires
ukrainiens et américains confirment que
les Kinja ont été abattus par un système
antimissile patriotes ce qui n'avait
jamais été vérifié jusqu'ici
coïncidence troublante un groupe de
scientifiques de l'Institut de Mécanique
théorique et appliqués de novocybirk
signe à l'unanimité une lettre ouverte
pour faire libérer trois des leurs des
concepteurs justement des fameux
missiles kingjal arrêté pour retraite
ans il risque la prison à vie les
scientifiques appellent à l'aide des
soutiennent que la répression contre
plusieurs de leurs collègues menacent à
long terme toute l'industrie militaire
russe ainsi les dernières nouvelles
venues du Corps US sont de plus en plus
confuses
du Dombasle ouvertement le ministre de
la Défense ergy Shogun et le général
Valérie guirassimov tout le monde sait
dit-il que ce sont des voleurs des
imbéciles massive
et le chef du groupe Wagner evgny
Prigogine prédit encore une fois la
catastrophe il implore le ministre et
l'état-major russe de tenir encore
quelques jours à barkout pour empêcher
les flancs de céder devant l'avant
ukrainienne car l'armée ukrainienne
tient bon à bark out malgré les
bombardements de plus en plus intenses
sur ce qui est déjà un tas de ruines
elle tient encore grâce à une seule
route d'approvisionnement en vivre en
armes en renfort et pour évacuer les
blessés demain
contre-offensive du Joker ce chef
d'unité d'artillerie si la route est
coupée tout le monde va mourir ce sera
la même chose qu'à Mario Paul good
Jean-Michel du Canada Montréal